nobody cares about shakespeare in los
angeles
did they hate him the people in the
audition room they thought i was
psychotic
i imagine it is called the evil a most
miraculous work of this good king
since my here remained in england i have
seen him do
i mean like what the is he doing
he's on buffy and then finding out that
that
that insane man got the role he's just
like i quit
forget it you know you know and you hear
about this because i'm one that could
relate to you about the you know the
hair and the bleach and i had to shave
my head so we could relate to it and
so but like it it burnt it really burned
your scalp like it hurt oh so bad
so bad yeah but it because it was just
because
we had to do it every episode we had to
do it every
every eight days because a vampire's
dead so your
the hair doesn't grow so you can't have
roots so
on the bottle it says only do this every
six weeks it's not safe to do it more
often than that we were doing it every
eight days so when you when you when you
bleach
you would get blisters you get blisters
on your skull uh because
it's really heavy chemical um and so we
were we were pouring
bleach on top of the open wounds from
the last bleaching like
every eight days did you think that you
were gonna maybe not grow your hair out
like you're gonna lose your hair you're
gonna go bald you're gonna be scarred
for life
yeah they would say we don't know if
you're gonna have hair by the end of
this and i was like
screw it pay me i'll buy hair you know
like after after
after 15 years of abject poverty i you
know the hair was my last concern
wow i was just trying to make money to
because i became a father so i moved
down to los angeles to try to buy
diapers and health care and stuff like
that and so you know at that point
hair schmidt smear